on est marié depuis une éternité et si
je met bout à bout les moments que nous
avons passés ensemble ça fait combien de
temps en réalité du sud
jégo journée toi toi tu as toujours les
grosses journées bien pleine
mais moi j'ai des longues journées très
longues bien vide
pourquoi tu me l'as toujours gagner et
toi savez je vous connais ma vie au père
et non se souvient pas je suis désolé sa
vie était gens si tu n'es pas le premier
à qui ça arrive tu vas tu arrêter un peu
ce qui cette fille que tu raccompagné et
vous conduit à vous c'est quoi j'ai
jamais rêvé de rien c'est sans doute
seul problème la vie m'a roulé comme un
caillou je laissais faire venir
n'importe où c'est quelqu'un qui connaît
son service et la maison en même temps
ce sont des bouquets c'est pas des
menaces de mort
tu veux me parlez parlez de quoi je me
rappelle toujours dans les moments durs
santé ce que tu penseras mois pour les
autres
je me suis c'était un ce que j'ai fait
pour toi depuis 30 ans
si je te disais voilà demain tu peux
faire ce que tu veux tout ce dont tu as
toujours rêvé que tu n'as jamais pu
faire
tu ferais quoi